it's like an ollie i thought she was hot
throughout the whole movie yeah
she was pretty hot hot she was pretty
hot she reminds me of sarah her body she
uh tall and beautiful and gangly kind of
like i'm gonna say something about sarah
by the way that might make you feel
uncomfortable she's beautiful
but
i i
she's funny love her so much all right
like so much i do too and the friendship
that we've built in the last couple
months you and sarah
has been
one of like i just i'm so thankful that
you introduced me to her interesting
that's fun i just like the fun times
that's the that's the good news
that's that's makes life all flourish
i love that i love that you're being
friends with my exes but she's also so
nurturing and she's so warm she's a
crazy person
i mean we love you sarah three in the
morning right where's sarah she comes
into the bedroom in a ballerina costume
you know what i mean and she does a
sketch now
that's fun
right yeah yeah that sounds so cute it's
cute and fun
it's crazy too
she's crazy but so are you so i know
yeah but um i
in my heart
there's a gigantic spot for her i don't
blame you i think in my heart now too
yeah yeah and i in my heart
i thank god every day that i met her
and um
i just think that she's a great person
i miss her in a weird way there's some
people that are sort of like salt of the
earth just genuine like a mensch yeah
she is the mensch
yeah you you never deserved her jesus
[Laughter]
let me you might
look defend yourself why you deserve her
this is good i'm [ __ ] up what got my
this is what's good this is what got me
the energy energy right here now you got
you got it you tapped into it he was
always too good for you
he was always too good for you all right
you know how many good steve was too
good for you
he was i will admit that okay absolutely
i thought that was going to start a
fight
yeah your face i was going to start my
face was kind of surprised yeah yeah i'm
like oh throw it out there oh it worked
all my ex
there's a good chance all my exes were
too good for me that's why you and i
have been together so long because our
our level of [ __ ] upness is a match
yeah
like we deserve the monstrosity out of
each other i haven't been a saint in my
life you haven't either so you and i are
both wild we're wild and you have um
we're not
[Laughter]
let's talk about acting out no we can't
talk about it we'll talk about it a
little bit don't be afraid you and i
definitely act out we do act out and i
think that um
but let me defend myself when it comes
to sarah though
you don't have to i do want to i think
that you number one
here we go number one
yes
if you were to open up our insides
and you could it you were able to
display
in front of scientists yeah right
the goodness in inside you right okay
laid out there
mine would be in like a little shot
glass let's say goodness is a liquid
form okay like ounces
[ __ ] god you're so good man it's ounces
man yeah
eight ounce 12 ounce you know what a
bright guy
yeah ounces right she would have like a
[ __ ] they would have buckets
and mine would be in a shot glass
you know i mean but
um when i met her
i think
here's let me just can i just
here's what's great about me
oh okay
no you want to hear oh yeah i love to
hear this all right all right i
understand
what's great about me
is
number one because i'm so needy
right
and also that i also am very kind of um
i take care of people
i'm generous so generous right so it's
like you know at the time when i met
sarah i was doing okay in my life you
know financially and in career-wise as
well she's a comedian right so i was
able to introduce her to different
aspects of
you know what i do what we do you know i
mean as comedians introduce her to
people you know try to do this thing and
it's like um i i think that we both
helped each other
you know but i don't think it was just a
one-way street
i have things to offer
you do you tell you how much you have to
i'm not a [ __ ] machine
you're not you're me you're not no no
but hey bro
i've seen the movies
right and i'm also biologically inclined
to know how yeah okay so let's move on
he knows how to climb a tree real well
hey that's another slam bump on my side
no
another slam about my size
no but i'm a good person i think but
you're right she is better than i am
here's another what we're talking about
she's not
the reason why you're acting out what
was the most recent act out you guys
have had
candy
a lot of candy
you know what i had i had a cleaning
lady come here and she asked me why are
there so many sunflower seeds in the
ground oh that's one way he hacks out he
every single package from amazon that
comes to the door
is bags and bags of different
brands of sunflower seeds
wow you collect okay no it's not a cold